What's up guys, I'm hanging out again with my good friend Richie from the Sonic Dad Labs.
You might remember him from a video where we got together and built this thing. This is a 25 millimeter cannon powered by alcohol and shoots at an impressive speed
So out of the blue one day Richie says,  "I've just been playing around for fun and i have made this little missile  for the cannon, what do you think?"
And first of all I love it, because its black and yellow, its totally my colors
The second thing that went through my mind was, some of your comments said: "why don't you try making exploding ammunition?"
So I asked Richie: "can we put some kind of a pin firing device in here that would hit a primer cap?"
And make these things into impact sensitive exploding missiles
How do you actually design a missile like this Richie?
Well I have a 3D CAD system, basically you know, I start with the bore of the barrel and go from there
Figure out the ratio I want for the length and diameter
I actually looked at some more shell designs because I really liked the shape
and this is kinda fashioned after some of the mortar shells out there so I think it looks pretty cool
So the primers are the little cups that go on the back of your bullets
and when the firing pin from the gun hit them
it causes an explosion to come out to other end and send your bullet flying
Now when you add your primer you want to add with the inside of the cuffs facing inside the shell
so that the flat end is sticking out.
And that's so that when the nail hits it it will fire inside the nose cone.
We're going to use a bit of superglue around the base of this retainer, that's going to help hold it in place in the nose cone.
My fingers are going to stick together in a second
Then we use some activator here
This stuff helps the glue harden  a little bit quicker
Now there's a couple of ways we could go with this desing, guys
We could take a primer cap, set it in the tip
and then insert our nail
and now we basically got a glorified cap dart
that will go off with a tremendous amount of power
But for this project, we thought
we would take it up a  notch , by introducing a little bit of black powder
The way, that Richie designed these nose cones
is, we can actually pack them up with about four to five grams of
a black powder equivalent
Then we will use a little bit of hot glue
to form a bulk head and put the tail fins in place
once these things are put together they're actually very very safe
it's not until you add the nail to the tip that they become active and ready for use
this is a muzzle loading compellent but its still really fun to play with
a little craft foam divider will help separate the black powder from the hot glue
makes it a little bit safer and helps hold it in place
and then we just seal that thing up
Beautiful, thats beautiful looks just like liquid glass
so there are 2 different variations that richie's made
one is just the nose cone that we fill up with powder and then basically glue the tail into place
the second one here is a little bit different, it's got a chamber for the powder on the inside
and then an outer chamber that we're going to fill up with baby powder
the idea is that when these things explode its gonna spray powder everywhere
and make it a little bit more noticeable infact
you wanna put the baby powder around first, so I've got this whole piece that goes in
keeps baby powder out of our (gun)powder chamber
and then a funnel
Grant: ah he's thought of everything
so I'm just using a little del to help consolidate this (baby)powder so that i can get in as much as i can
you know on, on this design the nose cone is really thin out here so I'm actually going to put the glue around the center where its thicker
otherwise the glue would melt the nose cone
and just put that down there
there is nothing you can't do with a little bit of hot glue
you remember that Richie designed this barrel so that it just pops right off
and now you cant take your ammunition and push it up into the barrel
and then is just slides right back in to the ignition chamber
and it's ready to go
so we've got our two variations set, the glue is hardening so all I have to do is repeat that process now
over and over and over again
multiply it by thirty
improvised party horns
so there you have it guys, with a little bit of time and with Richie's amazing brains
we've just put together a whole arsenal of these little exploding missles
which hopefully will go off on impact
unfortunately we can't test them out right now because we're at the golf course
we need to head out deep into the desert because we're gonna make about thirty more of these things and test them all out
so you'll see that in the next video
in the mean time go over to the Sonic Dad channel
they've got a smaller version of this cannon that will shoot marshmallows
and I'll put a link the description to where you can go and download the pdf for FREE
the Sonic Dad team has amazing and they're all very kid friendly
so go check them out SonicDad.com
Richie: Thank you grant! it was fun doing this project with ya! :D
yes it was! :D YEA *fist bump*
CHEERS :)
Richie: and they go off
ahahah yea
You're welcome for the subs :) don't forget to leave a thumbs up and subscribe if you haven't!